you might think the boy is put together
like a lot of other superhero shows
green screen CGI and army of effects
artists and it is but we're fairly
certain the effects crew on Smallville
never asked for a blood covered the size
of a small house homelander and queen
Ma's first scene shows them flexing
their might in the same way you might
see in a Marvel project but unlike every
single ugly ass frame of quom mania I
feel like I'm hugging Godzilla the scene
actually utilizes practical effects to
accompany the CGI you believe this is a
call out Kevin the scene of Queen mave
going stiff to stop an armored truck was
mostly made with practical effects the
crew used wires to dragg the truck into
a big metal pole instead of you know
driving a car into their actress they
also captured a shot of Dominique
mceligot jumping in front of a green
screen the two were then combined to
make it look like she was the one
turning the truck into tinfoil to make
it look like Queen ma was actually
inside the truck as debris flew around
her the team built a special set the
whole rig was on Wheels allowing it to
be moved around the actual as a famble
on it once everything was put together
and debris was added with CGI the
sequence looked less like vehicular
manslaughter and more like a superhero
doing her job in real life New York
standing on the edge of a curb means
that you might get hit by a cyclist or
the corner of a bus in the New York of
the boys it means you might be instantly
vaporized by a Speedster high on super
drugs so it's more like La my deepest
condolences to Robin Ward's family if
Robins never turned into human spaghetti
sauce the boys would be a show about a
reasonably happy retail worker living in
a world that's slightly more interesting
than our own I'd like to make an
appointment for you to come over
and lay some cable in order to get a
beautifully Dynamic look at the worst
day of fur's life the scene was filmed
in front of a green screen with a
phantom high-speed camera at about 500
frames per second for non-film geeks
that's real
slow the crew positioned the camera on a
big robotic arm so they could move the
camera quickly enough to get the perfect
shot of actor Jack Quaid looking like
he's front row at a Gua
concert visual effect supervisor Steven
fleets told V effect voice what you're
seeing there when it's rounding around
huy is one second of time being slowed
down as for Robin's disintegrated body
and the blood splattered on huie the
team made a valiant effort to use
practical effects Kevin feige but the
result didn't quite look the way they
wanted they ended up using CGI rather
than dumping a bucket of blood on Quaid
like he'd just been crowned prom
queen that meant that the final decision
the team made was exactly what the reign
of Gore should look like as Fleet put it
how much of Robin do we see how much of
her guts do we see how much blood do we
see what's the trajectory it became
about the storytelling so basically the
VFX team behind the boys is Dexter
Morgan look at the blood P look at the
patterns it tells a story Fleet also
admitted there's probably more blood
than a real human would have but it
would would be a lot less interesting if
it was a real situation well yeah if it
was a real situation huy would just be
stuck with recurring nightmares and
lifelong therapy bills as the defender
of the Seas and a bootleg Aquaman the
Deep loves all the animals that call the
water their home he really loves them
like biblically speaking despite his
best efforts though the Deep's
relationships often end in tragedy he's
watched several of his Marine buddies
die in horrific fashion like that time
in season 3 when homelander forced him
to eat his octopus buddy Tim what isn't
that
delicious before that though the Deep
made a splash in season 1 when he got
his dolphin lover killed drawing a bued
aquarium Escape dolphins are the ocean's
[__] in general but this one in
particular was kind of a sex pest okay
okay if I just touch it will you shut
up when the cops surround the Deep's
truck he hits the brakes flinging the
horny mammal through the windshield like
it's an aquatic Final Destination a
passing truck then finishes the job by
notching what might be the first first
recorded case of dolphin
roadkill since production didn't have a
bunch of disposable Dolphins lying
around what are they SeaWorld the boys
use the next best thing puppets and CGI
for the crash the team built a green
dolphin doll as well as a special device
to throw it into traffic like a giant
batting cage for sea life as Steven
Fleet put it it was kind of one of those
funny nights in visual effects you know
you're working until 5: in the morning
launching green dolphins out of a car
been there Steven been
there soov VFX later replac the green
dolphin with a CG version that looked
more like the real deal and a lot less
nerfy Fleet added they also came up with
the idea of him flopping on the ground
before the truck hits him those little
details make it great oh this isn't
domestic abuse this is hilarious despite
being invisible and getting killed off
pretty early the super cool translucent
makes a memorable impression he mainly
uses his power to be perhaps the world's
most successful perver but he's also
capable of stripping down for the
ultimate sneak attack naked and unafraid
translucent ambushes Huey at work but
after throwing out a few cheap shots
he's interrupted by Billy butcher's
speeding
car Butcher and translucent engage in a
bloody fist fight until huy exploits the
soup's shocking weakness note literally
being
shocked the shots of butcher ramming
into the store acquired a duplicate set
that the stunt coordinator rigged
complete with its own rail system and
Camera both were linked to a green
wrecking ball on wires that was later
edited out and replaced with butcher's
car the setup was motion controlled so
the team could repeat the movement
destroying the store as many times as
they needed to until they got the
perfect shot invisible actors are nously
hard to find was Kevin Bacon
[Music]
unavailable so Butcher and translucent
fist fight was filmed in multiple pass
with some classic movie Magic first they
had to act out the choreographed fight
with a stunt double in a moap suit who
was later erased after that the actor
repeated the entire fight by himself I'm
not supposed to talk about what that
reminds me of what the hell are you
doing oh as the brawl continues
translucent ends up partially visible
when butcher spits blood on him the team
used a stun double as an animation
reference for the blood spatter and also
for when translucent takes an electric
Shar straight to the ass that would have
taken me forever work that one out I
don't think it's controversial to say
that homelander is kind of a dick he's a
toxic coworker a crappy dad and he likes
milk in all the wrong
ways gross he's also a homicidal maniac
but to the Vault Corporation he's an
important asset Synergy at the end of
the first episode of the boys any
possibility of homelander being a
crusader of Justice goes down in flames
when he assassinates the mayor of
Baltimore and his sun in their plane
with his laser vision to create this
shocking scene the crew filmed
homelander actor Anthony star hanging
from wires in front of a green screen
then combine that footage of CGI to
create the final effect this technique
also applies to basically every big
budget superhero movie ever made you'll
believe a man can fly and brutally
murder a child homelander uses as laser
eyes throughout the show to do
everything from killing Cold Blood to
heats up his milk and it was during the
production of this particular scene that
the visual effects team ref find the
look of his most memorable superpower
Steven Fleet told befores and afters
there's also a lot of subtlety and a lot
of breakup in those lasers that make
them slightly unique from your average
CG laser eye gag and they play into his
character they say you can tell a lot
about a person from their eyes if
they're glowing red it probably means
they're about to kill you well hug your
kids right cuz you never know what might
happen every superhero's story needs to
escalate in the sequel except Ant-Man
apparently but I really want like a lime
right so in season two of the boys the
Deep goes from flinging a dolphin to
riding a
whale as is tradition though his Animal
Companions always meet unfortunate ends
and poor Lucy is no exception she takes
a speedboat straight to the side
covering everyone around her in tons of
blood and GTS like that party and blade
except way less singing and
dancing gross the shocking moment was
conceptualized by writer Craig Rosenberg
who fought to bring it to the screen
showrunner Eric kpy told Entertainment
Weekly I think he specifically wanted to
top the dolphin I was initially
reluctant but he argued that there are
only so many more times the deep can
kill marine life through his sheer
incompetence the Deep rides lose he into
the path of the boy speedboat hoping to
force them to stop unfortunately butcher
decides to speed up instead of slowing
down impaling the whale and knocking the
Deep out cold no no no don't Flor it
okay FL it as the visual effects team
told variety the boat was poured on a
rail by a string into a model version of
Lucy meanwhile her entrails exploded out
of cannons spraying 150 gallons of fake
blood under several stunt doubles like
that party in Wednesday except way less
singing and
dancing gross the entire set was built
by hand over the course of 5 months with
numerous crew members taking the time to
painstakingly recreate a dis embowed
whale carus will harvest your
blood the effect supervisor Steven Fleet
that there's only one blue screenshot in
the entire sequence and it's when the
deep is on the whale much like Aquaman
is the king of Atlantis the deep is the
king of getting aquatic mammals
vaporized by vehicles have you ever had
a migraine so bad it felt like your head
was going to
explode for some unlucky government
officials in season 2 that nightmare
becomes a messy reality starting with
CIA deputy director Susan rainor during
a congressional hearing about compound V
it's not long before skull start popping
scanner
style cpan is finally must C TV speaking
with Corridor crew Steven Fleet revealed
that much of the head explosion effect
was developed in season 1 when
translucent was taken out by a C4
suppository and what
now after that was designed he got
tipped off that there would be plenty
more head explosions to come in future
episodes his technique required what the
VFX team referred to as a blood lollipop
gross which doubles the the actor's head
and is used to drench anyone near the
victim with fake blood the computer
Graphics team then made a cranium model
filling in the larger chunks of brain
and bone as they fly in multiple
directions okay someone else is doing
the next Boys video finally the beheaded
CGI body is given what Fleek calls the
necklace the meaty flap of skin that
remains on the
body he bragged this is one of my
proudest accomplishments of season 2
from a supervision standpoint it's okay
just admiring the shape of your skull
this confirms what most people already
knew the boys is a show for sickos by
sickos oh God in season three of the
boys it seems like the crew are finally
going to find their Ultimate Weapon in
the fight against homelander to their
surprise the weapon they discover is a
powerful and problematic World War II
hero known as soldja boy you help me
find the rest of my team and I'll help
you with this homelander with a
patriotic name and the ability to level
buildings with radioactive bursts soldja
boy is basically Captain America with a
personality disorder and nuke in his
chest he's also High out of his mind in
other words this is the only guy on
Earth who could feasibly take on
homelander and fans couldn't wait to see
her you think you look WR strong you're
wearing a cape knock it the big battle
finally took place late in season 3
interrupting herogasm which is a massive
superhero orgy it's an intense braw that
interrupts some of the craziest sex acts
you've ever seen which is either a good
thing or a bad thing depending on what
you're into but soldja boy doesn't fight
homelander alone Huey and butcher lend a
hand high on their own supply of temp V
stunt coordinator John coyama took the
lead in bringing to life a superhero
fight for the ages Steven Fleet told
befores and afters he'd film it like a
full-on movie he would shoot coverage
he'd send edits he'd get notes I think
he did 12 to 16 versions of that
sequence alone before we even filmed it
many of the stunts involved a collection
of wires and green screens and the gaps
were filled with computer Graphics the
most challenging part of the sequence
was quote getting that iconic shot of
Butcher and homelander hitting each
other with lasers and finding the right
balance between making it that thing
that everybody knows in movies where two
lasers hit each other but not making it
over the top because well that's not our
show as one of the boy's only good guy
characters starlight's ability to
project light couldn't be more symbolic
I am so sorry are you all right but
bringing her powers to life takes a lot
more than just setting off some
fireworks a season 1 Showdown with a
train took the VFX house frame store at
several intense weeks of work in an
interview with denif geek Fram store
executive producer Christopher gray
revealed the real world science behind
The Shining soup's Powers he explained
we looked at a thing called fto
photography which is like a way of
visualizing photons he referred to a TED
Talk which describes the Imaging as
visualizing the world at one trillion
frames per second for nonscience geeks
that's real slow it's a tech you need to
make the only camera fast enough to put
a train in prison for exploding hu's
girlfriend one of the boy strangest
turns is when black noir has visions of
obscene cartoons committing shocking
acts of violence to help him dig up
repress Memories the cartoon sequences
were a fan favorite addition to the
series but developing the hybrid scenes
was a complicated process there have
been vast advancements in this type of
Technology since Michael Jordan and Bugs
Bunny made
out the development and animation of the
cartoon characters was done by six-point
harness and team in between Steven Fleet
told befores and afters onet who made
cutouts to scale of the characters all
of them I mean my office was filled with
cutouts of these cartoon characters we
were juggle popping them into frame for
reference lineup sometimes even acting
out character motions I'm sure there's
some really goofy dailies out there that
someone could use to embarrass us
hopefully it stays locked down because
you definitely don't want footage out
there of you doing
this fck you [__] behind the
scenes it turns out that making a fake
version of the Avengers looks a lot like
making the real version of The Avengers
or at least last minute re-shoot against
a green screen in an airplane hanger
Kevin feige a subplot featured
throughout season 2 of the boys is the
development of a big crossover movie
Dawn of the seven the in Universe flick
even received a real world trailer
debuting as a meta teaser for season 3
of the boys VFX Studio Rising Sun
pictures revealed much of the work that
went into making this mock movie with a
special making of breakdown filming was
completed on practical sets designed to
simulate a city in Ruins including a
broken down bust and the Standard
Concrete Rubble that every superhero
movie is legally obligated to have a
green screen was used to add in the
apocalyptic background showing VA Tower
Up in Smoke the end result somehow looks
better than the SN
cut you're welcome let's talk about the
giant penis okay maybe it's not giant
but perspective is everything right
fellas the last scene we're talking
about is pretty unforgetable ible no
matter how hard you try to erase it from
your mind it's not going anywhere in the
season 3 premiere called payback a size
shrinking supernames termite shrinks
down so small that his entire body can
fit on the head of a pin or the tip of
a we're not allowed to show it we can
barely even say it so just read between
the lines so termite shrinks down for a
trip into his partner's love tunnel but
while he's giving his mate the old
reverse kidney stone he accidentally
sneezes and shoots back to normal size
for his boyfriend this is nothing short
of the Apocalypse termite is left
shocked and covered from head to toe in
blood the craziest thing about this
scene might be where they got the idea
turns out the writers saw all those
memes about Antman beating Thanos by
crawling up his butt to go big mode you
hear that internet this was literally
your fault what's funnier than this
scene is what the set looked like when
they shot it using a mix of practical
effects Kevin and CGI the props that
term I used this needed to be superise
including the chwy climbs inside in an
interview with befores and afters V
effect supervisor Steven Fleet revealed
the arts department built a practical
penis entrance set an 11t high 30ft
longish representation of the penis the
Practical entrance was key for the
performer to do his fantastic and very
real Swan Dive one of the biggest
challenges for the team turned out to be
the climactic explosion they used CGI
for the big moment though a blood bag
was also used for reference but honestly
they could have done it any way they
liked no one knows what this is supposed
to look like it's never happened before
right don't answer that I don't want to
know